ready is this goes on a kid Kai talking
about Dragon Ball super this will be a
weekly installment where we review the
new episodes today's episode is 39 so
kid Kai initial or should I say kid
kaio-ken yeah hey caio can I like that I
like that initial thoughts on the
episode what do you think um where to
begin honestly best episode so far I
seen her super on like you can try and
say some earlier episodes by by far in
my opinion the best episode I've seen so
far like not counting that movie
episodes or just hands down hands down
its the best of that so do not maybe you
can argue with the movies but movies are
movies and no I just think as an episode
this is by far the best honestly like we
got so much content out of it that I was
surprised how much we got yeah I just
want to comment on like the complete the
complete change from dragon ball z or
even dragon ball kai to Dragon Ball
super there's way less filler and it's
almost moving too fast if that's
possible for Dragon Ball Z like no
complaints on the pacing thus far yeah I
definitely have to agree with you on
that for sure I mean the thing that
about the old dragon ball z series was
is like some of the sequences like the
fight sequences lasted 19 episodes i'm
referring to goku vs frieza on Namek
which was kind of like one point gets to
be like okay man once this stuff gonna
end already but even though i was epic
about it was epic it was epic don't get
me wrong but sometimes you just want to
move on and see what happens after but
as a whole i'm definitely loving the
super thing in the faster pace and you
know hit as a character he is very
impressive you know I love him gotta say
I love him even though he kind of does
his character design does remind me of
cooler in a son's butt is but it's cool
believe it or not it's cooler yeah
cooler and cooler is what I like about a
yeah for sure and well what I'm thinking
is this this season like all together I
wasn't
a huge fan up till this point I kind of
like the idea I learned like the super
bad guys like the kind of animation of
the bad guys is getting almost too far
out like that big bear and like it was
kind of like turning me off for a little
bit but with hit by tomorrow every
answer yeah yeah it was completely cool
right cool draw and now this is the
first fight actually Vegeta kicking
frost yes free gold universal but that
was kind of surely this kind of seemed
like yes pummel them every Indian kid
Kai were kind of talking about this like
what school is not that it's no longer
just like oh I'm gonna level up higher
than you I'm stronger than you now
they're actually incorporating skills
and strategy to the game the metal guy
with from the that spits fire lava like
that guy actually used strategy right
even though he wasn't necessarily
stronger than the gia so just seeing
that kind of development I I see a
different direction the show is having a
different direction that it was before
its continued to end of innovate and you
can't just do dragon ball z again right
that's why this show is good because
they're doing new stuff and they're even
the styles changing up like you seem a
lot more metafiction as you'll see in
let's say one punch man then you ever
did before you have piccolo joking that
Crillon should not get involved because
it'll might die again you have you have
Vegeta saying que Cara why do you always
get to play the main role even in this
episode you have them finally answering
like the question we've been wanting to
know why hasn't Goku ever used kok was
super saiyan like I thought of that
about that a thousand times before but
he's explained that that that kind of
transformation they just can't go
together because it would be too tough
of a toll on the body all this new Super
Saiyan can so that's super saiyan blue
so that's something I really enjoyed now
an interesting thing is is like I was
wondering the whole time what his new
trump card will be and the way the way
the fact that they used kaio-ken or
you want to pronounce it was like a very
pleasant surprise to me B because it's
like something old something we've had
about before like why haven't they done
it and it's you know I honestly don't
think I've seen karl ken being used
since like paginas you're likely to saga
Freeza Freeza to be fair freezer to be
fair i also think it's interesting that
we finally have as Crillon pointed out a
fighter who's who's copying goku's
winning pattern right usually goku is
the one who overcomes and becomes more
powerful during the battle and then
finally beat his opponent now that might
happen again but it's cool that with hit
we finally have an opponent who is the
same and grows perhaps even quicker than
Goku does and it's so interesting how
they incorporate now this time leap so
it's no longer just hey I'm stronger
than you I'm getting faster than you now
that they're bringing in almost fourth
dimension they're bringing in more
complex things to complicate what we
thought was the DBZ universe they're
bringing in more technicalities more
complexities which are making it to be
fair very interesting yeah like for
example hits time leap ability that's
that's such an interesting ask me
because honestly without that time leap
ability I probably feel he'd get
pummeled easily by Goku because frankly
hasn't shown anything right now that's
surpasses Super Saiyan God Super Saiyan
blue or super saiyan blue times tenkai
ok and polish which one times ten key 1
times oh it was just like wow wow this
is amazing like at this point I think he
might even be on par with beerus or
maybe even slightly stronger in him he's
still nowhere near strong as weas but
he's getting there he's showing
interesting well to be fair if if the
Creator dragonball z said that goku
would be a 6 if beerus was a 10 Goku has
how many times improved his strength
right now right but he's not the weird
thing is their power scalings really
and how they do it and it's highly
inconsistent and how they do it because
beerus beerus look very worried and even
wiese looked at him in kind of game like
are you worried sort of cable which was
hilarious i love that they out of that
which to me signals that he is he's
stronger possibly on par or stronger
than beers while we siz still not
worried that he still looks like he
could potentially because we don't know
men we don't know they said that we siz
a 15 if goku was a six and beerus was a
ton but who knows akira toriyama is
known for his inconsistent power skiing
for all we know he could be a 30 sure we
don't know we don't know he could choose
to make him so much more powerful and he
could always be misleading us on purpose
to mess with our like perceptions
definitely he's definitely doing that
and i think what's interesting is that
even if beerus maintains his lead right
now i'm wondering if he can he can
accelerate at the same pace as goku cuz
goku for the longest time we thought
yeah maybe he's not the strongest but he
has the biggest potential to grow but
then freezer came along who showed that
with less training he can get further
ahead and then Cain now comes along hit
so really we're seeing other people
other races as opposed to the Saiyans
who can rise quicker with less practice
yes yes yes because as we know what
gives sends their incredible potential
as there's an cai with intense battles
they can grow by healing over time but
now that Frieza was brought back and you
find out he had no need to ever trained
or anything in a form on sees surpasses
super saiyan blue God which is
incredible to me it's a bit over
exaggerated is because he was to hire
there's so much weaker and then with
four months I mean if they said over a
three-year period okay I can believe it
by lake for months but then now you get
hit who's grows by the minute or by the
second it appears like his my his
potential might be even greater than
freezes because like he even said it
himself he had no need effort to improve
because the need never arose but now
it's like he is improving almost as fast
as goku
is by using kaio-ken which is like
insane insane and this is just as
natural potential it's not a technique
use master so I don't know I think it's
interesting all in all I think I like
super I mean sometimes the animation
does go bad you can see for split I mean
they fixed it a lot by the key yeah i
like i like the animation and some
people it turns it off but i definitely
got used to it and some of the fight the
fighting scenes like you can't complain
about that they definitely been solid i
also was considering doing different
just reviews talking about the first and
second movie which we might do later on
but right now kid Kai I was wondering
when you think of this fact that finally
finally we had Vegeta and Goku equal
pushing each other I loved it and then
again Goku is now one step ahead what do
you make a lot you know what honestly I
was so happy when they brought the gia
back on par with kokor I mean they push
each other it's as simple as that Boko
would not make sense for Boko to keep
getting shorter itself aegina i mean he
doesn't it's not as obvious because
Vegeta and the earlier dragon ball z
saugus has a like a very unhealthy
obsession with the fact that goku's much
more powerful than him but yeah I'm glad
that they brought him back and then in
terms of coke was stepping up like it's
not I won't say it's a full step ahead
because he's not it's not a different
transformation it's a technique that
he's known already he's half a step I'll
say if he's half a step ahead of Vegeta
which I don't mind as long as the G
defines other ways I don't want it to be
like where was the god-awful GT where go
cause two transformations ahead of
Vegeta that was just gone awful and I
wanna know I did like how true I did
like how to Super Saiyan 4 looks that
was one of my favorite transformation I
think it looks cool I hate that show but
I honestly thinks you're still for looks
cool I'm not gonna it does look cool no
no worries about that what I think about
that is yeah like it's so good seeing
people pushed her because that's how
reality is like that's how we just watch
hajime no ippo together you always see
people pushing each other together and
you need people allies as well as rivals
as well as enemies to keep pushing you
to get better that's why I hit wasn't
improving that's why Frieza wasn't
improving and once you put someone in
the mix whose clothes you both keep on
getting better which is why I really
hope that
doesn't lack behind for long and I
actually want to see this I want to see
Vegeta become stronger than Goku for a
time like I don't want to see Goku just
one step but Jay catching up Goku once
that I want to see it switch it up a bit
i want to see Vegeta sometimes gets the
upper hand that would be cool to see
yeah I think that's been implied though
but like it's for a short period of time
like when he was the first one to go
train with six months with wee seng on
their planet it's implied during those
episodes that he's is slightly stronger
than Goku but like at the same time it's
not really shown in fighting it's not
shown in sparkly usually a meaningful
way I want I want Goku to be a bill
little jealous you know I want going to
be like oh man I want catch up to him
but not to Regina like it's interesting
because his character is really weird
like that because he's so chill even if
you Vegeta was ahead of him hehe just
give that Goku smirking haha he's just
okay oh hey I accept that challenge of
yours that I'm going to catch up to you
personally I've always felt that has
been implied that go cross slightly more
potential than Aegina doesn't keep in
mind i don't like it i like he is
younger i think five years in Vegeta I
know you don't like it but like it's
kind of interesting because Goku is a
low class and warrior that's risen to be
their greatest warrior ever with Vegeta
neck and neck like if goku's attend
vegeta's a 9.9 in terms of potential I
don't want I don't want to hear that but
but but but that does not mean without
hard work that Vegeta can get on par and
I like that they keep putting him on par
which is nice because it's made it more
interesting quite frankly when Goku gets
ahead so much it kind of becomes bland
and also I do like the fact that they've
made to go on start training again
that's yeah how is actually gonna bring
that up a highly I really really want to
see a resurrection of the epic Gohan
notice say a man I want to see go on get
back in there and actually be like a
contender right I don't want to see him
just fall be hot yeah yeah go on being
great too please don't remind me don't
remind me of the gay say mm it's just
not don't don't not what I want to see
well we've been through
not this conversation you have any final
remarks yeah I hope they keep it up man
we got a lot of contacts in this episode
I'm i hate I hope they keep it up and I
can't wait to see who the the result of
the fight which will be between a goku
and head I think it's going to be
something interesting that we're not
expecting I've seen a lot of other
YouTube channels where they predict and
I'm glad a lot of times they're way off
because it wouldn't be interesting if
these guys could get will guess what's
going to happen and you know there's a
lot of speculation with this huge akira
toriyama recent interview you know
people suspecting maybe Future Trunks is
coming back blah blah blah this and that
but you know we'll see what happens
maybe he won't come back I'm starting to
think that accurate Oregon was maybe
reading some of these things and seeing
what we're saying and then he's just
changing it up do you know what ya ice
what do you think will win this you want
to make a call I'm gonna sue draw draw
I'm gonna say it's gonna be some kind of
we were draw I think they're gonna
because they're gonna have that one
menaka who was expected to supposed to
be so much stronger than them it is like
we know we know as a [ __ ] like
because he passed them from goku's first
kamehameha wave so we know he's very
weak he's extraordinary week but because
I feel like it's gonna be a draw I think
I heard this may be from someone but I
don't know it doesn't matter oh yeah cuz
this bit it's a draw makes no way cuz
he's there yeah because I'm oh that's a
good theory that's a good there I can't
claim that as my own I feel like I might
have heard that from someone so I'm just
gonna say that's what I feel like it's
gonna happen though and yeah I want to
see so far oh yeah I'm happy with the
way it's going I know it's gonna slow
down after the next episode but you know
it doesn't have to be fast paced not
every second has to be fighting yeah
yeah all in all I'm very hot room what's
going on so far yeah we're very excited
and this has been super Sunday's with
anime uproar and we'll see you next week
as always see you space cowboys